this is officially the best junket
question I've ever asked in my life who
do you think pooed in the P bucket we
did that day on set try to guess you
remember yeah did I say that someone
said it's probably sleepwalking Ty I
think yes I don't personally agree but
it's funny if it was you and then you're
the person who gets so mad yeah
I don't know I mean that makes sense
it it could be misty it could be misty
it could be Crystal I don't think it was
crystal for some reason Crystal's my
pick because she keeps her on the number
two card oh that's funny I'll deal with
it anyway that's true maybe it's Ben
um you
you give me a break maybe you
missed his question is it a girl poo or
a boy poo isn't so far like I don't know
makes me laugh so kind of funny I mean
I've heard all of these answers in the
other room so I think you're all on to
something
um serious question for all three of you
given what your characters went through
in season one what particular event is
weighing most heavily on them and your
performance in season two like the thing
that's on your mind the most when
justifying their decisions now I don't
know that I have anything specific to
say I just wanted to check well yeah I
feel like
um the scene with my dad really was the
biggest turning point and I'm so glad we
had that because that taught me a lot
about Natalie
um oh yeah yeah I think that would be
the one and it's funny actually because
for me with Ben it's it's similar
because
um I feel like most of the decisions
that I make with her are often traceable
back to the scene in the pilot where
she's slap some other awake
um and then and Lauren and I talked
about this a little bit too at the
beginning of season two there was
something fascinating for me about the
idea of it's it hasn't hasn't been
explored in the show yet but like just
what it would mean for van to have like
an unpredictable alcoholic parent who
she's potentially in a care position of
yeah and and in my mind I was like okay
so what does that mean that means you're
dealing with somebody who says things
that they don't remember saying can't
always be trusted with their own
physical safety and isn't um uh
necessarily in control of their own
behavior and then it's like when taisa
is sleepwalking we're talking about
somebody who says things I don't
remember saying can't be trusted with
their own physical safety and does
things they don't remember and I was
just like oh no like so I'm particularly
in the early episodes of season two that
was weighing on me I was wow that comes
through big time yeah jeez for Ty it's
the fact that she didn't that she failed
in her Mission like her purpose was I'm
the leader I keep everyone safe I'm
gonna get us out of here not only did
she fail in getting everyone out so
maybe it's her fault that they're stuck
here at winter and then this baby is or
isn't coming and XYZ but it's also her
fault that Van's face got messed up and
like that everything that happens after
this everyone we lose everyone that gets
sick is because she failed in her
Mission like it's a lot my heart because
you brought up winter I'll ask a
somewhat silly question what is the key
to playing cold someone once told me it
was really difficult to like fake act
cold and now it's stuck in my head it's
hot yeah it's um it's a lot of like like
holding your like chest and arms like
trying a lot of attention as still as
possible you end up with like the days
where I actually remembered to pretend
to be called the whole time I would
always go home with like a really sore
back oh yes I was always
I'll give you my one silly would you
rather question that that idea came from
I ask it every once in a while would you
rather have to fake sneeze in a scene or
fake vomit in a scene oh God I'd rather
fake vomit I did all right sneezing
sounds really sneezing sounds like true
that was so bad I did fake vomit in this
like in this this thing that never sold
a lot of day but it's I I the fake
moment that they gave me was like um
milk and potato chips and spinach oh I
don't have to like have that in my mouth
and then spit it out I'm gonna real
vomit I don't ever want to do that
that's a very specific combination but
it was very effective
stew yeah mine the season was like stew
nice for songs not so bad
salty this is the most Twisted thing
I've come up with but I feel like there
should be like a like a fake vomit menu
somewhere I would love to hear about all
the different variations there are
um before I go full spoiler here live
obviously a very hot topic of
conversation right now is how van was
supposed to die in season one so what
was your very first response when you
found out that no like Not only would
van make it through season one but the
character would wind up being a massive
component of season two as well I found
all of that out very very gradually so
like as as we were
as we were finishing filming season one
I was like I think
they are keeping me on this television
show
um and then and then it was a matter of
like oh if if we get renewed we'd like
to make you a regular I'm like okay so
you are keeping me on this television
show and then later it was like oh we
are riding adult van it's like okay so
great and then and then later it was
like okay Lauren's coming on board so it
was very it was very incremental and at
every stage I was like okay so don't
move don't say anything and don't annoy
anybody no like
um because I just wanted so badly uh for
this to happen um and I count myself
very lucky that
unfold with the way it has